مره اخرى تكشف الشرطه لندن عن المجرمين في
صفوفها ويرتدي زيها وتعترف بانها تجاهل
التحذيرات ارتكابه الجرائم
لقد خذلنا لندن كاندي
وما فعله بضحاياه امر بسيط حقا وشجاعه
الابلاغ عنه امر مثير للاعجاب
ضابط الشرطه لمده 18 عاما النساء
المستضعفات وارتكب جرائم بحقهن واعترف
كاريك امام المحكمه ب 94 منها 24 حاله
اغتصاب طالت اثنا عشر سيده ضحاياه شعارنا
بانه لا يمكننهن التقدم بشكوى ضد في وقت
مبكر لانه قال لهن لا احد سيصدقهن هذه
الفضيحه شوهت سمعه الشرطه ومصداقيه الناس
فيها مضاربه
النساء بالشرطه
ليس لدي اي ثقه في جهاز الشرطه خصوصا وان
شرطيا حاولت تقرب مني بهذه الطريقه عندما
كنت في شبابي
فضيحه الشرطه ارغمت الداخليه على تقديم
احاطه الى النواب
لاعضاء البرلمان ان الحكومه لن تخجل من
تحدي الشرطه للوفاء بالمعايير التي
نتوقعها جميعا التغيير يجب ان يحدث وبصفه
وزيره الداخليه سافعل كل ما في وسعي لضمان
ذلك
بانتظار يصطاد حكم مدتي سجنه طردت من
الشرطه التي تعرضت للكثير من الانتقادات
لسلوك عناصرها في السنوات الاخيره اطاحت
برئيستها السابقه هذا الضابط المدن ليس
الاول الذي ارتكب جرائمه وهو يعمل في جهاز
الشرطه ولن يكون الاخير مع تاكيد رئيس
مفوضيه شرطه العاصمه انه هناك العشرات من
اعضائه يخضعون للتحقيق بشان ما زعم سوء
سلوك الجنسي او العنصريه مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن